au niveau universitaire au moins dans le
cas de la France l'impression que j'ai
comme consommateur d'histoire pas comme
historien c'est qu'en fait les il y a
deux écoles qui rivalisent et rivalisent
en qualité ce qui est excellent mais qui
du coup appauvrissent les autres
approches il y
a je simplifie abominablement les
historiens vont me taper dessus mais il
y a
l'école
mondialiste
Boucheron donc histoire mondiale de la
France et puis il y a l'histoire Pierre
Nora nationalocentré alors absolument
pas nationaliste on peut pas accuser
Pierre Nora d'être nationaliste mais qui
pousse à s'intéresser à ce que ont été
les origines historiques
culturelles de la nation française de la
République française de l'État français
les monuments les grands ouvrages les
trait de P et cetera y compris la
régionalisation de et entre les deux il
y a pas
l'Europe et alors j'invite
max à faire comme moi alors évidment il
faut
attendre tous les mois de décembre quand
je fais le Père Noël je vais à la plus
grande librairie de de chez nous qui est
la
F et j'aime mais mais mais vous pouvez
le faire pas loin d'ici à la librairie
des sciences politiques rue Saint-
guuillaume j'ai fait le même exercice
devant le directeur de Science Po il y a
un ou deux mois je lu dit mais écoutez
venez vous ne croyez pas venez regardez
ce qu'il y a en vitrine pas un titre sur
l'histoire de l'Europe de l'Europe pas
un titre sur la construction europenne